[Música]
escala en París ahí da Palau
Bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio Francia internacional y France 24
Hoy les hablamos de cine de leyendas de
ladrones internacionales chilenos de
mitos y realidades lo hacemos a través
de la película otro sol que se acaba de
presentar en la primera edición del club
el festival de cine latinoamericano de
París hoy recibimos al director de esta
original cinta que viaja entre la
ficción y el documental el director
chileno Francisco Rodríguez te haré
Muchísimas gracias Francisco por estar
con nosotros muchas gracias a ustedes
por la invitación Bueno usted es
cineasta estudió en Santiago de Chile y
también en Francia de hecho vive entre
Santiago y París ha hecho varios
cortometrajes y mediometrajes Boys una
luna de hierro y Apple telefonic entre
otros ha participado en festivales
internacionales de todo el mundo de cine
pero también en circuitos de arte
contemporáneo contemporáneo y ha
recibido premios en el festival de cine
Valdivia en chile y también en el
festival de punto de vista en España y
en 2020 el Festival Internacional de
Marsella aquí en Francia le dedicó una
monografía a sus películas y vídeos otro
sol es su primer largometraje y en él
Investiga la historia de un ladrón
chileno Alberto candia que había habría
robado los tesoros de la catedral de
Cádiz en 1978 la trama se sitúa en la
actualidad en el desierto de atacama y
también en Cádiz en España rezuma es un
poquito de qué se trata otro sol
se trata de reconstruir archivos del
pasado
de filmar ciertos territorios como el
desierto de atacama y Cádiz y de mezclar
la realidad o las experiencias de
ciertas personas
con
archivos de Justicia que es algo que
hace un tiempo que vengo trabajando
me interesa mucho escarbar en archivos
de justicia y considerarlos materia
disponible para poder hacer adaptaciones
cinematográficas Como quien hace
adaptaciones de libros la historia
empieza con un Buscador de oro que
cuenta a cámara que le está enseñando a
su sobrino la profesión de buscador de
oro y en un momento dice esto
que lo que hacen estos cerros están
llenos de tragedia donde hay oro hay
tragedia
aquí no ha ocurrido muchas cosas
este oro está lleno de gente Así que
se han pillado y lo han dejado tirado
estos cerros están llenos de tragedias
donde hay oro hay tragedia dice el
buscador de oro está lleno de cuerpos
que se han dejado tirados unas frases
que indican ya un poco el tono no de que
tendrá que tendrá la película que
anuncia como una tierra donde se
esconden muertos secretos ladrones
criminales Cómo se le ocurrió hacer este
este largometraje indagar sobre la
historia de este ladrón chileno Alberto
candia que no sabemos muy bien si
existió existió no Alberto candia
Alberto candia hay mucho yo creo y es un
personaje compuesto de muchos personajes
La idea inicial si voy como al inicio al
inicio es
hay un mito muy local en chile que es el
de los lances internacionales se llaman
hay libros que se llaman lanzas
internacionales hay una banda de música
incluso que tiene su nombre y cuando uno
le hizo un chileno un Lance
internacional todos entendemos de qué
estamos hablando es
un una persona que se dedica al robo
hurto
afuera de chile Generalmente en Europa o
Estados Unidos yo
pensaba o tenía la idea de que era un O
sea a mí me interesaba mucho
indagar en Por qué pensamos que tenemos
los mejores ladrones porque también el
mito de lanza internacional trae eso
trae la idea que tenemos los mejores
ladrones al internacional
y eso siempre genera una suerte de
orgullo pero también vergüenza por parte
de las personas
en Chile Entonces yo pensaba que era un
mito muy muy local y yo me decía Cómo
hacer que un país con 17 millones de
habitantes tiene los mejores ladrones
del mundo
y el punto de inflexión fue cuando me
doy cuenta que en diarios ingleses
holandeses australianos
Se confirma el mito Entonces no era solo
una leyenda local no era solo
claro un mito construido solo en Chile
lo confirman lo confirma la policía de
scotlangiar Y
ya dije Bueno aquí tiene que haber algo
y lo que me interesaba era entender
Buscar la Fuente
después conociendo a personajes o
personas que entrevisté
se me olvidó esa pregunta inicial y en
algún momento teniendo una conversación
con los personajes me di cuenta que
tiene una razón histórica y es que
Durante los años 70
El dictador pinochet quería a todo costo
controlar el
tráfico de pasta base y cocaína en todo
el territorio nacional el mayor
traficante chileno se llama Augusto
pinochet y es lo que llamamos la cocaína
negra de pinoche entonces cualquier
persona que estuviera relacionada de
forma directa o cercana con un delito
menor
no era juzgado no se le pregunta a nadie
se le torturaba directamente
eso hizo que toda una generación de
ladrones o personajes que se dedican al
hurto tuvieran que irse a países donde
podían ejercer su oficio sin que se les
torturaran y empiezan a crecer a crecer
a crecer y Durante los años 90 80 90
hay una gran digamos comunidad de Ladrón
chilena internacional con técnicas muy
desarrolladas de robo muy complejas
este largometraje a veces parece ficción
a veces parece que estemos ante un
documental yo confieso que fui a mirar
por Google si el ladrón Candy había
existido o no
es un documental o es una ficción la
gente que habla en este en este
largometraje dice la verdad cuenta sus
propias experiencias
es la verdad
o su verdad no sé imagina el ejercicio
de Porque para mí por ejemplo es muy
importante los alias el hecho de que una
persona porte alias Imagínate yo voy por
la vida con ni siquiera diez pasaportes
falsos voy con un pasaporte falso que
dice yo me llamo Dino Franco romanati
Pero tengo una aula italiano tengo un
acento en italiano la gente se pregunta
por qué me llamo así porque tengo un
acento en italiano y yo empiezo a
construirme una una identidad y voy
caminando por la calle imaginándome que
soy otra persona
eso produce mucho vértigo y
y al punto en que yo mismo puedo empezar
a confundir mis propias realidades y mis
propias biografías en función de
de mi ficción o de mito propio
[Música]
a mí en la escuela de cine me acuerdo
que me decían que un documental es la
promesa de que lo que está viendo el
espectador es el mundo
que yo como espectador y los personajes
de la película vivimos en el mismo mundo
que habitamos en el mismo mundo
Solo que
la en el caso de esta película eso se
fractura cuando vamos
cuando quiero hacer una adaptación de
archivos judiciales y la pregunta es un
archivo judicial es
real o no la pregunta quizá una de las
preguntas fundamentales de la película
qué tanto y de verdad en un testimonio
judicial pues es uno de los ejes
de la película No porque se va oyendo
una voz que va leyendo archivos
judiciales policiales
la muerte es algo que le interesa mucho
y de hecho en la película representa un
cadáver con una oreja no solo una oreja
Me ha parecido como muy daliniano no sé
si es una de si pensó en esto no Pero
ver una oreja sola no
la oreja viene de una historia que
cuenta uno de los personajes que cuenta
que que Teresa uno su mamá le cortó la
oreja a este famoso Alberto candia
la imagen Es como muy delineada sí puede
ser no O sea sí no no estaba pensando en
salir seguro no era solo en base a esta
historia bueno igual una oreja una parte
muy extraña del cuerpo es muy atractiva
y sobre todo esta oreja que se va
moviendo de un lugar a otro o sea
aparece en el principio de la película
acerca del del mar y después al final de
la película
aparece en un río en la montaña o sea en
un lugar que no tiene nada que ver
cuáles son sus influencias
porque hay algo de surrealismo también
en esa oreja que
que se da muy bien latinoamericana en su
mayoría
cuando estaba escribiendo esta película
estaba leyendo mucho un libro que se
llama Zurita de Raúl Zurita
una obra de poesía narrativa
surrealista por momentos
sobre el desierto de atacama y sobre
cuerpos y o sea cuerpos encontrados en
el ser atacama también
estaba leyendo a Blanca Varela que una
poeta peruana que me encanta del siglo
XX y de ahí viene el título y de ahí en
el título de un poema de Blanca de un
poema de Varela qué tiene entre manos
porque nos ha nos ha impresionado mucho
Esta película Nos gustaría ver ver más
cosas y tal vez me comentaba antes que
igual habría tendríamos más noticias de
estos personajes pero sé que tiene
cortometrajes también En postproducción
cuéntenos cuáles son sus proyectos que
tiene entre manos
cortometrajes Sí más que cortometraje es
gestos pequeñas cosas que filmamos solo
o con o con equipos muy reducidos con
amigos
uno se llama octubre al mediodía y y
medio que son conversaciones alrededor
de de la revolución de octubre en Chile
que tuvo lugar
y proyecto de largometraje claro Hay uno
que
esperamos filmar de aquí a uno o dos
años también cerca del desierto atacama
la ciudad de antofagasta Y puede que
hayan algunos de los mismos personajes
en vista de que son son buenos actores
bueno otro sol se ha presentado en el
festival de cine latinoamericano de
París era su primera edición Cuál fue la
acogida del público
bien lindo festival
latinoamericano
y una programación muy
ecléctica pero bien organizada un
público fiel
no muy lindo o sea es como un panorama o
sea las películas que yo fui a ver Era
un panorama bastante interesante y
diverso de lo del continente
bueno Francisco pues muchísimas gracias
le deseamos muchísimo éxito gracias a
ustedes gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir por internet en RS y
mundo.com y en France 24.com Hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]